and that's a sharpie um what is my
favorite animal gag from the whole six
seasons of the show
it's it's impossible to pick one one
that comes to mind which is actually
written in the script that I think about
a lot because I'm very proud of it was
there's an episode where a ferret is
talking to Henry Winkler at a funeral
and being very inappropriate for the
funeral and Henry Winkler kind of shuts
her down and says I'll let you get back
to your business and gestures to a group
of other ferrets and a group of ferrets
is called a business of ferrets that is
a joke that delights me because I think
it's thing you might not notice on first
watch if you don't happen to that's that
piece of trivia yeah mostly I just sit
around the house and complain about
things yeah yeah how's that working out
for you
man I can't complain so it first started
because I was friends with Lisa Hanawalt
who is a brilliant artist we went to
high school together and we would joke
about you know one day we're gonna make
a cartoon together and we had various
terrible ideas but I always have wanted
to work with her on stuff and then she
went to UCLA and I went to New York for
college but we stayed in touch and then
we kind of switched places she moved to
New York and then I moved down to LA and
I started pitching shows you do a lot of
meetings here in Hollywood and so I got
you got any ideas
yeah I got some ideas we'd love to hear
them here they are okay well let us know
if you have any ideas I just told you
all my ideas what happened so I came up
with like three to five ideas and I said
eyes think about what direction my life
would take if we'd gone with one of the
other ideas instead of Bojack horseman
so I wanted to do a family comedy set
during the reign of terror in France
where the dad was a guillotine salesman
and business was booming but he couldn't
get his wacky family in order so that
was one idea I had I was gonna kind of
like all in the family but like in
France and his kids are gonna be
revolutionaries and like the ghost of
Marie Antoinette and be living in their
attic I think was gonna be called the
good times are killing me I think was
the idea because his the guillotines are
you know selling like hotcakes and
eventually I ran out of ideas what else
what else can I do what else can I come
up with and so I went to Lisa's blog and
I pulled a bunch of her drawings that
she had made because she'd been drawing
these animal people on her own and I
thought okay what can I do with these
but at the same time I had just moved to
LA and I was living in this house up in
the Hollywood Hills that was like a
friend of a friend of a friend's house I
somehow was paying like $800 a month to
live in this glorified closet in a
beautiful mansion and I don't quite know
how it was arranged but I remember the
rumors amongst the housemates
that was the third highest elevated
house in all of Hollywood that Johnny
Depp had lived there once there are all
sorts of secrets in the houses it was on
the on the top of this Hill up this very
windy road that I immediately got into a
car accident on and then I didn't have a
car and I was stranded up on this house
and I remember looking out on the deck
over all of Hollywood and feeling
simultaneously on top of the world and
never more isolated and alone I didn't
have any friends I didn't know anybody
and so that was the beginning of the
character for me the idea of this this
guy who was living in a house like this
who'd had every opportunity for success
but still couldn't find a way to be
happy so it's kind of that married with
Lisa's style is where the show came
together Joe was never the same after I
left admit it some people prefer the
later years the character Bojack was not
written with will in mind I think he
might be delighted to know you know
who'd be a great
washed-up sad lonely actor Will Arnett
no you know it was written just as for
Beau jag was written for this drawing
that Lisa Hanawalt had drawn of this
horse guy and then once we were
developing the project we thought you
know before we pitch this around it
might help to have some talent attached
so Linda LaMontagne is our casting
director and she kind of drew up a list
of you know here are some actors I think
would be right for this and as soon as I
saw Will Arnett's name I was like Oh
yes that's the guy because he's so funny
but there's also a darkness to him and I
feel like in his you know gravelly
performance you feel like he's lived a
life and there's like a sadness lurking
underneath there but again he's so funny
I mean there are lines that we have made
Bojack say that I would not have the
hutzpah to give to an actor because
they're so dopey but that I knew that
Will Arnett could pull them off like I
remember in the writers room like
looking at a line scripting like click
this line and this is so stupid
and we do the table read and Will Arnett
reads it and it's the funniest thing
you've ever heard oh my god you took our
dumbest stuff and he spun it into gold
and that's what you want on a chair you
want someone who elevates the material
and I am so blessed with our cast that
just every single one of them elevates
the material every single one of them is
better than the jokes you give them like
you can give them setups to jokes and
they make the setups funny you can give
them sad lines and they make them tragic
you can make them give them sad lines
they make them tragic and funny at the
same time somehow one of the funniest
things I've ever heard was Will Arnett
going what what the line was what and he
kills it yeah you know that is mr.
peanut butter Paul is also hilarious I
mean Paul is an incredibly talented
actor his instincts are dead-on and also
I think he preps I think he looks at the
script beforehand and makes choices and
thinks how am I gonna do this line what
is the funniest way to do this so he
comes in and he's just overflowing with
funny ideas you know when I was first
writing the character of mr. peanut
butter I initially heard him in my head
as like more of like a meathead more of
a deep kind of gravelly like a patrick
warburton type you know you can kind of
imagine like the big lunkhead but
because we cast will who has this deep
voice and then we cast Aaron as Todd and
Aaron also has a pretty deep voice I
felt like I if we have a third deep
voice guy it's just gonna get repetitive
and boring and so I wanted someone with
who had like a higher register and I
thought Paul had this beautiful lilting
quality to him it almost feels like he's
skipping across the line which I think
as a foil to Bojack is very funny that
Bojack he just even
his voice is very kind of sunk down and
in the muck whereas mr. peanut butter is
is playfully skipping above the muck I'm
responsible for my own happiness I can't
even be responsible for my own breakfast
I pitched it as a show that is gonna
start very fun and goofy like most adult
animated shows but by the end of its
first season it's going to turn into
more of a drama D along lines of a
live-action show like a girls or even
Mad Men I think we're the examples I
used at the time which felt a little
more unprecedented in the world of
animation to indulge that much in
seriousness and emotion but that was the
ideas that we were gonna trick people by
making people think it was a typical
animated sitcom but actually by the end
of the season they'd be going oh my god
why do I have feelings where did this
come from I think in my plan I always
assumed the audience will join us on
this ride and go from oh this is fun
this is silly to oh my god I have
feelings it never occurred to me that
some people might see the silly part and
go not for me click and not even know
that the rest of the show turns into
this totally other thing I think if I
were doing it again I might try to
include more clues at the beginning that
this was a more serious show but even
then I think it's hard to do because
there are clues in the beginning and I
think because of the context of it being
an adult animated show people didn't see
those clothes because they assumed they
knew what it was right and so they saw
the clues that affirmed what they
thought it was but they missed the stuff
that didn't point in that direction in
the first episode of the show Bojack and
Diane have like a two-minute
conversation on the fleeting nature of
happiness right so that should be a hint
that like oh that's what the show is
really interested in but I remember
reading reviews of the first season and
one said you know for a show that is
meant to be just wall-to-wall jokes
there sure are a lot of scenes that
don't have that many jokes and I thought
you're so close your first instinct is
what is this like that I've seen before
and I think what I tried to do was make
it kind of like what people had seen
before but also have one foot in
something kind of new
and challenging and I think if I were
doing it again
I wouldn't spend as much time in the
what audiences have seen before I don't
think they needed their hands held as
much as I thought they did I think
audiences were ready for something new
and something different because that's
the thing that I really loved about the
first season is that it did that change
and that it was both of those things
that it wasn't just one or the other and
so when we were working on season two I
definitely felt the confidence of like
let's go further in that direction
because that's what the show is that's
that's the sweet spot that's that's what
people are interested in is this
emotional stuff wall at the same time
it's a goofy silly fun cartoon where did
the theme song come from that's a great
question so Andy Gowen is our music
supervisor and he kind of put the word
out to a bunch of different bands and a
bunch of different artists hey you know
we're here's a new show we're looking
for some some music and we had a lot of
responses and and the to that kind of
rose to the top for me was this very
playful sing songy group love song and
this very heavy spooky Patrick Carney
and Ralph Carney song and I remember
there was a lot of debate over which
song are we gonna use and then we put
together this main title sequence the
director Mike Roberts but there's an
incredible sequence of Bojack kind of
going through his day and we played
different songs over to see what felt
right and we'd bring in people from the
crew we did focus groups and was like
pretty evenly split like people love the
group love song and people loved the
Patrick Carney Ralph Carney song and at
the end of the day we thought could we
do both and so we ended up using the the
Patrick Carney Ralph Carney song at the
beginning and the group of song at the
end I think they do different things in
really fun ways you know I really like
that the the Carney song has more of a
spooky melancholy feel to it I think it
is a little bit of a hint of what's to
come in the show and it does make you
think like oh this feels a little more
dramatic than like a typical animated
fun sitcom and then I think the group
love song kind of the opposite is so fun
and bright and at the end of some of our
efforts
which are really downer endings like it
almost feels like an ironic like you
know poking the ribs like it's it's
almost taunting and it almost brings out
the emotionality in a fun new way
there's also darkly humorous and so I've
really enjoyed using that song as
juxtaposition against all these
different endings especially as the show
has gotten more and more serious it's
it's kind of revealed itself to have new
layers to it
[Music]